ashley is in Syracuse New York I
actually our you hello Dave um I'm a
major submerge couple my husband is 59
years old has no retirement shaved
we got three children youngest of 8
months and 32 so I'm kind of concerned
on him I don't want to work his
retirement away and not spend time with
him to get him
retired any money safe we are working
out baby step 3 right now so you don't
have any money saved for retirement at
all nope
and he's 59 yep okay yeah Ashley I mean
as you all sit and look I want to
encourage you to do a few things step
number one is to have that dream meeting
to really sit down I want you to find
out what is his what was his dream what
does that look like and then I want you
all to take it another step further and
start to lay out options on how you can
make up for some lost time here that
dream may look a little bit different
but in tapping it in with him and
talking about that start to identify
what are some things you can do now now
another thing that you mentioned you
said spending time with him right yes
okay I want you to understand there's a
difference between quality time and
quantity of time you guys have a young
kid that you're trying to take care of
and so you know the weekends the
evenings that's spending time with and
so as you all are in uncovering options
maybe you do you work outside of the
home I'm not right now okay but how'd
you be going back okay
okay see here's the thing he's 69 in 10
years you got a 10 year old and so what
Chris is saying is is that somehow we've
got to prepare yes you need to spend
time with him but somehow we've got to
prepare because not not being cold
anything but statistically he's going to
leave you behind with some little kids
right and the only thing that's going to
fix that is either life insurance or
savings yeah it does it does he have
life insurance yeah okay is it outside
of the job does he have term life
insurance or something within the drop
yes long term okay he's got long term
care insurance um no just um basic life
insurance
okay term life insurance okay okay and I
would want you to also reach out to an
endorsed local provider have a
discussion have them review that policy
let's find out you know if there's some
extension that can be done or if there
are some gaps you guys got some work to
do and and it's one of those things I
love hearing that you're working and
talking about it together
but we need to lay out a game plan for
the sake of this eight month old here's
the deal you're gonna have some hard
times you're just going to have to
choose when they're going to be in this
case you're going to you're going to
buckle down hard for the next 10 years
or if you don't then you're going to
have some hard times after he's gone
yeah exactly
and so you've got to do the math and
what I want to do is I want to choose my
poison if I'm in your shoes I want to
choose which way I'm going with this and
so I think it's probably wisest make
sure that life insurance stays in place
and you guys get very very serious about
the management of every nickel coming
into that house for the next ten years
okay they've got to buckle down and
here's the thing that Ashley can also do
for her husband he's probably feeling
guilty Dave that he doesn't have
anything and he's got this young kid and
so guilt can make people stop trying and
so as a spouse she can encourage him to
let him know we're not going to Harper
on the past we're going to focus on the
future and focus on what we can do not
what we didn't do
yeah very cool hang on actually we're
going to send you a copy of Chris's book
retire inspired because we want you to
have that inspiration both of you to do
what it takes to be able to pull this
off if you hold on I'll have Kelly pick
up and we'll get that done you know the
deal is it doesn't matter what your
situation is everybody's got some unique
twists into their situation that was a
unique twist a little different thing
that because the math all the sudden
goes crazy in your head you and I are
used to crunching these numbers so fast
and being able to answer a question like
that but it the math in that situation
changes but the bottom line is is if you
will just apply yourself there's an
answer to these equations yeah I don't
care where you are financially there are
things you can do for yourself I want
you to look at your budget find some
areas to cut back you
can find money to start to invest and if
you have to take on a part-time job
direct that money toward debt or direct
that money toward investing I want you
to focus on the things you can do not
the things you haven't done and that
just changes perspective for people and
it's more encouraging than it is
defeating now sometimes folks face
something and they can't see the way out
so they do nothing that's what we're
talking about earlier yeah and so it's
really important to sit down start to
break it down step by step dollar by
dollar year by year and here's what we
can do and so here's what we have to do
to be able to be where we need to be now
and it just it shifts everything it
changes everything around hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you